[Music]
in it counts news submitted by Rachel
from NYC that's New York City Oh for
those of you own it don't know about
that a burpee controversy explodes after
a woman breaks the Guinness World Record
for burpees
how many Burpee you've what what yeah
there's a controversy though 2000 what
is the love prosthetic legs and so it
gives her bounce yeah burpees are
[ __ ] hard by the way yeah maybe she
wasn't completing the burpees well she
got she broke a world Dennis so that was
a burpee controller there she completed
1400 d in one hour - that's impossible
really Mike doing [ __ ] the video of her
Burpee streak went viral mostly because
people hated it she was cheating or that
we'll see why unless see what a burpee
where her Burpee is okay
I thought that was her Burpee I was like
oh hell now hand burpees what the [ __ ]
kind of Burpee is that does it count
are you serious again it's world record
account that's why I see that he's still
an amazing feat yeah yeah 1490 of those
that's still really big I thought this
is a big part of the Burpee know the big
part is you laying flat on the ground
yeah then jump to the floor yeah well
honestly that's so hard though your abs
are cramped up [ __ ] up but that's not
that is not a burpee I guess she
understood the loopholes yeah I mean I'd
like as long as your hand leaves and in
your foot you know that's probably how
they do the Guinness World Record Burpee
right but that's not a qualifying Burpee
in the Spartan Race I'll tell you that
mm because every time you miss an
obstacle you have to do 30 burpees and
guess what there's someone watching you
when you do your burpees do you go
stomach to Florida I supposed to go
chest the floor yeah just the forms
right yeah supposed to chest they're
like a push-up and then yeah and you're
supposed to jump on your feet have to
leave the floor - yeah I do that - yeah
so she says that her coach and her
decided that they would she would stay
as close to the floor as possible in
order to minimize energy output for
maximum number of reps but she's like I
definitely know what a verbal order look
at her she definitely knows what a
burkha she's yeah yeah
I mean I guess it's not her fault if
that's the rule yeah yeah I mean people
that go on the Guinness World Records
like they're gaining that because I mean
why do the full Burpee if you don't have
to exactly
yeah so she uh she was a personal or she
was a former personal trainer so what
does she do now break records I was I
was curious cuz I'm pretty good at
pull-ups so I wanted to see what the
world-record pull-ups
were and then there gaming it's you like
your guys Alec hella like pull it up
pulling pull from here there's nothing
like this that's it
not even like gym above the bay but I
was the same thing that's not to clear
the chin but they're just this wide
where the bars here are the range of
motion
if I saw it's like doing six inches
instead of like all the way down yeah so
I mean it's your choice you can do it
here you can do it here but I think the
most in a minute was like 50 50 pull-ups
I'm like oh [ __ ] that shit's crate or
around there
that is crazy I don't know if I could do
one pull-up dude this is crazy
life's insane huh God makes people never
tried doing a fool I feel like the last
time I could do a pull-up was when I was
210 pounds I thought you could 60 years
old
no hello it tears was amazing but I
couldn't do a pull-up because I could
pull this this hurts all right I just
okay the shoulder twice Oh God oh this
bungy motion just doing this yeah it's
too hard at this weight so if I'm at 200
pounds I should be able to do pull-ups
again and so like you can't really once
you dislocate your shoulder it's never
the same again yeah so huh and I
dislocated twice how first time was
benching actually because I don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so you just you do this and you kind of
squirm you know like nobody like they
didn't have like this [ __ ]
information on the internet back in the
day and so you just big bro [ __ ]
workouts and so I was trying to squeeze
up while I was maxing out and it just
went pop boom oh God and the second time
did we just run scratch themselves no
stuck in it and it pulled out you lying
oh yeah the [ __ ] blanket talked you
out yeah trying to sleep boys on it
unsalted and so it's going to do they
submitted draft one of the high thread
count though oh yeah Egyptian yeah it's
a good snug told you up scared over
folks when bad things happen issues is
what it is
I'm happy you're alive thank you Joe
that's still really hard to 1490 of
those yeah I mean people talking [ __ ]
they just need a [ __ ] do it
themselves even if you just tried
touching their toes like 1,400 times
that's a lot anything forty number times
it's buggin wear you out you know and if
you want to [ __ ] spend the time to do
that [ __ ] good for you we gotta give a
round of applause for the people
watching it too and count the
counter dude it didn't move counter
you just didn't good you're just at
three oh yeah definitely should it call
that burr piece you can call it the
scared cat I like that yeah so she took
up the challenge to raise money for MS
Australia which is an advocacy
organization dedicated sclerosis you get
paid for because unless you feel society
maybe she had like sponsors and [ __ ]
like try to break a record she ended up
raising 5615 up until this point good
for her half of her goal or it was ten
dozen multiple sclerosis is a thing in
the brain right where there's like
multiple scars on the finger on the
brain or something does it affect your
um your muscles and [ __ ] doesn't it you
deteriorate because like I had a history
teacher at the Terri Asian of the myelin
sheath know it's a disease in which the
immune system eats away at the
protective covering of nerves yes the
myelin sheath or it is a deterrent okay
if I remember yeah so is there a way to
heal that or not just [ __ ]
physical therapy and medications that
suppress the immune system can help with
symptoms and slow disease progression
yeah you start atrophy and lose control
of all your extremities and appendages
yes I had I had a history teacher who
got diagnosed with multiple sclerosis
and she was known as like the teacher
who was like the [ __ ] strict this
woman on campus when my brother had her
as a teacher but by the time I got to
her she was about to retire she was I
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis and
like she just you know it was so sad
dude cuz like if from a woman who was
like cuz they're like the strongest
female in our school yeah and then you
see that happen it's so [ __ ] sad yeah
that's yeah I loved it to death because
she allowed me to sleep on the floor in
class
dope teacher because I took weight
training before and then I remember the
first day two-way street I never
disclosed before and I will forever
remember this because my legs I try to
sit on my chair and I collapse and I hit
my face on the desk Oh God and then she
was like what happened I like I don't
[ __ ] know
it was because my [ __ ] quads were
torn up I never had that pain so I
literally was I just couldn't get
so she was like you could just sleep on
the floor she let me sleep there
sleeping class cuz I just couldn't get
up
I went ham I thought if I came in fetal
position just yeah first first first
couple we should let me sleep a little
bit in the beginning because I was I was
pretty weak that's a dope I had a dope a
social studies teacher who I would
always like I would always go to sleep
his class got to be so sleepy and then
um but I would still get good grades you
know I'm saying it's like he didn't pick
on me so he would also I remember one
day after like a couple weeks he was
like alright now we're gonna start with
laughs Tim's gonna go to sleep and now
we're going to sew if you guys are
curious the previous records for burpees
was 1320 walk is it they've been doing
it that way then yeah that's the only
way guys ever read the Guinness yes when
I was like really young I got it for the
Scholastic paper thing I mean what is
this is it just a [ __ ] book full of
recommend literally the most random
records yeah
really cool pictures too crazy records
they got some normal like like what you
would think
athletic [ __ ] like the highest jump or
whatever then you got like the person
that could fit the most marbles in his
mouth yeah it's like it's like tallest
man and then like the longest beer [ __ ]
like that
he's nails like biggest booger on earth
maybe you ever seen the videos of the
the most snaps per minute that likes and
[Music]
everybody go swag sir
pretty easy anyway I got the try he's
like half away was that so hard for you
all the thing of the part that he just
played that specific yeah that one I
couldn't do that with him off tequila
I know but I'm like that's crazy I can't
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]